eu não sei o que tem nesse gravador de
celular que não sei o que a autoeuropa
processar whatsapp portal modifica a
minha voz porque eu vou gravar uma
narrativa zap bota aqui eu converso com
uma voz de locutor faletto do vento
chegando e daqui a pouco elas 18 e 26
anos chegando aí o windows ou nunes 11
melhor do peão solto agora que eu vou
escutar o rapaz minha volta parece nadar
a sida top ten do sul então chegando
ainda que é um pouco com meu nome também
ao acabou processado e aí olha que este
campeonato não você e aspecto bom vocês
galera eu tô com sério problema essa
bosta de cds e iphone é a que tem mais
um que tem um iphone iphone 6
acho essa bota todo dia dá um quebra um
cabo e cabo encarregado como facul a
merda já não tem bateria já no fim de um
seguro se não votar não tomaria com uma
como eu vou viver agora o cara pega o
carregador e explica em bola e rola de
hoje bota no pescoço enrola pa
ele leva na brincadeira bem antes e que
tive o satã de dentro desse campo chega
em casa bota na tomada ele pega planta
dois segundo ele para aí você vai ficar
um pouquinho e pega dois segundo ele
para você mexe de novo ele pega para mim
essa brincadeira vai e volta vai
carregando reparando carregando
preparando carregando vai parando sempre
sempre celular dois segundos carriço diz
gross um pressuposto teclado aquela
bateria de de nokia quero acreditar na
sorte que duran 76 tá no meio do pé e
apagar o kaká eu bateria do carro para
bota um nó que dentro pronto carro som
parece que foi feita a descarga é dado
um ovo foi pacto com satanás o impacto
com a eletrobrás já vamos fazer a
descarga de xira todos conectado na
tomada para energia pra você e quando o
cara tem que fazer acrobacia carrega
bota na tomada e tumba de carregar se
vai botando vai botando vai botando vai
tirando vai tirando o botão não teve
jeito que você vai botar no sábado
naquele desespero assim a que pertence
ao meu deus é meu deus do céu já tem o
que faz você relata 12% meu pai até
agora o que eu vou fazer da minha vida é
você colocar ele no pan
carregou você [ __ ] que pariu agora
tentam ficar assim até carregar todo só
que quando você olha o cenário que você
você está em cima de uma cadeira que
está em cima de um cachorro que está em
cima de uma bola em cima de uma criança
que ligando a bola cada um cachorro e
você não pode mexer não que se mexer
para carregar isso ela parar num lugar
chegou o pessoal que seja só vê a hora
que você não é crítica na bota no
celular e ele para de carreira passou
pela sua cabeça e seus amigos se
divertir self instagram e tem um estilo
que você né
caco chega button é preço quando
acontece isso ainda é bom o ruim é
quando você coloca bocha do carregado na
tomada coloca seu celular veio a pessoa
coloque o celular perto você passa o seu
celular
ali perto um carregador mas na cozinha
volta para o banheiro dorme tinha uns 11
já deve estar sempre você deixa eu ir lá
pegar quando você vai pegar algum fala
da [ __ ] tira o do carregador colocar no
dele e deixa o seu perto pra você pensar
que está carregando é um outro é ódio
não é porque ele tem trocado é por isso
não tenha avisado que ele tirou ponto
carregador toca no dia que não existe
frustração pior no mundo do que você
botar seu carregado na tomada coloca pra
carregar seu celular você sai e volta
pensando meu deus meu celular meu bebê
está 100% quando você chega num tá avani
carreira avisa que vai trocar a visa é
igual quando tocava na geladeira vez tem
sorvete vê lá pode sorvete até o que
feijão uma viúva cara botou feijão ou
criar um novo código então dos amigos né
quem for tirar o carregado abordar seu
celular enquanto grita sem feijão onde
eu vou saber que você tinha [ __ ] tá
carga celular pelo menos vão criar
expectativas porque é como que diz
aquele ditado que cria expectativa
acabou se queimando não não tem muita
sede ao pote cristã eo que eu tenho ódio
é quando a bosta carrega 100% cem por
cento mas ela tá sempre sem o thiago
carregado tiro do carregador 2007 que já
bem agora uma coisa que tem assombrado
muito nesses últimos dias é o seguinte
não tem coisa pior do que você está aqui
com seu celular 57 bateria da cimpor
segue você conversando aqui no a
desaproveitar dado duas horas da manhã e
só tá batendo eu tenho estou conversando
anti lock aqui só esperar a pessoa
responder
bloqueia e dó outro dia você acorda e
você tem que sair se olha não sei lá um
possível você percebe que vocês que se
ele voltasse lá pra cá regantes do me o
meu deu e na maior das horas que eu
sinto vontade de dar um controle e na
vida eu acho esse um por cento de
bateria óleo assim o papai por que me
abandonaste você tem que sair seguinte
olha você lá o que você dá uma taxa de
chorar
agora eu tô com o negócio é o seguinte
me disseram que bateria de celular ele
tem de ter um negócio é de carga né não
importa se é 100% cs 420% colocou no
carregador tirou foi uma caída na minha
cabeça só se meu deus agora tenho
esperança 0 a torre para ficar sem luz
enquanto é 100% tira a bateria tiro não
saiu de casa tem quem faça o ivan na
pizzaria não podem estar 90% salvando
assim não tem que sair agora vá com isso
o total de fora 86% espera de povoar com
isso corre filho acabou pegando fogo
a mãe
muito obrigada a assistir esse vídeo se
você gostou se identificou que mostrar
como amigos e está no facebook que vai
se portar no facebook e marcou amigos
comentários existe também no youtube
clique gostei avisar que também a galera
de maceió que dia 9 e 10 eu tô aí falam
o dia 9 gente dia das mães leva as mães
puxou está já tem três sessões lotadas
31 em uma quarta sessão também é de
maceió leva a mãe para assistir o show é
dia das mães é muito bacana informações
tudo aqui na descrição do vídeo há país
nenhum querem seguir no instagram duto
está querem seguir também para a
descrição do vídeo só consegui lá viu
muito obrigado nuno silva lê muito
obrigado desse jeito está aqui é nóis